foreign
Indianapolis what's up Drake
hey Dr John how are you today partying
man what are you up to oh not much just
on my lunch break out here talking to
you my first time my first time on a
podcast so I apologize if I'm not very
good at it well I've been on a lot of
podcasts and I'm terrible at it so same
team I promise you're gonna do great uh
what's up man
we'll make it through uh so call today
first off I'll start off you know the
conversation by saying that my family
and my friends mean the absolute world
of me and I'm I'm pretty blessed to be
surrounded by people that love me but
I've noticed recently I've become hyper
competitive
um with with my friends and sort of the
way that like I I've never really felt
like I stack up or that that I'm
um as good as or that I'm less than so
to speak and so really calling today to
get some direction as to you know how to
change that and and just be kind of at
peace with
um you know other people's success and
you know my stage of life and and so
forth so yeah um great question man and
I appreciate you calling this I think
the conversation is going to help a lot
of people so I appreciate your bravery
there
um you cannot be at peace with other
people until you're at peace with you
and innately
whatever is going on in your stage of
Life whatever you wish to be different
that's where the that's where the echo
is not in your friends and
um
what have you not grieved anytime
somebody says they're struggling with
comparison
um whether it's somebody's got another
job or a nicer car or a wife or a
prettier wife or a prettier handsome or
husband or whatever the thing is
it almost always comes back to
grief of a life not yet lived
and because I skip over the grief part
the Heartbreak part just sitting in it
for a season I wish this was different
and it's not
and possibly taking inventory of some of
the things that we are participating in
that's making it that way or dealing
with the reality that there's nothing
we're doing it's just not happened
until we do that the only outsources
rage and anger and blame
which by the way is our entire culture
because we have an entire culture who
has outsourced all reality to politics
and media
and so they are we're literally unable
to sit at home and say I wish my life
was different
yeah um
in terms of what what your original
question was what what have I not
grieved
um I don't I don't know exactly and it
it kind of sounds ridiculous to say out
loud but I'll say it anyway
nothing's ridiculous don't do that to
yourself or don't do that to my buddy
Drake
that's you talking Gus you talking crap
about yourself again I can do that on
this show I do enough of that for me
right you don't do that
um okay whatever your feelings is what
you're feeling dude just own it
no I
I all everybody's starting to get to the
stage of life I'm 28 I'm single right
and so everybody's kind of at that stage
of life where they're they're getting
married they're having kids they're
they're they're starting that stage of
their life and there's really nothing
more in the world I want than that
um and it just for one reason or another
um hasn't happened yet do you have
you're still young I'm 28. do you have
streaming services
do I have streaming services
yeah
do you um take
ballroom dance lessons
no I do not do you take jiu jitsu
no I do not are you in a running club
uh I do CrossFit that's kind of my my
outlet so you're an occult okay so do
you do um uh any sort of regular
religious services
yeah
I do a Bible study uh most weeks I
haven't in recent weeks because I've
gone back to grad school and time has
just been a little short but but
generally speaking Yeah so what I'm
getting at is I don't think it's the
most important thing in your life that I
don't think it's the thing you want more
than anything else in the world
and that's okay
sounds like what you want is you want to
have the life that you want and this
other stuff
and for some people that other stuff
literally falls out of the sky
a friend of mine said this is my sister
I think y'all are gonna get married I
can't be your friend anymore because I
can't be friends with the guy who's
dating my sister
and then we got married and now me and
him are great friends
that fell out of the Moon
is that fair no not at all
be so annoyed if I wasn't me
and
that doesn't impact you so the question
is not like
[Music]
um
the question is not why not me the
question is I've got a pretty good life
that I've chosen
and if I want to choose something else
maybe I have to make some different
choices because so far hasn't fallen out
of the sky for me
is that fair
that's fair yeah um and I I think too
I've in recent years really started to
make some some drastic changes and like
what um
well I started working out I mean I I
was way overweight now I'm not I'm I'm
slightly overweight now so I'll call
that progress
um
Drake
stop with that
if you were way overweight in your less
overweight now that's not I'm just going
to call that progress
that's one of the single hardest
transitions a human can make in the 21st
century it's amazing
it's incredible
and someone would be so blessed to be
sitting at a table with you with
somebody with your character and
discipline and willpower and joy
yeah
yeah I know I mean you're absolutely
right why don't you like Drake what is
so sucky about Drake
is that you were overweight what is it
no I just you don't like you man why
I I I don't know because I used to have
a pretty good radar and like instantly
you sound like somebody I'd like to hang
out with and I'm not just saying that
you know I'm not just gonna make that up
on the show like
you sound like a funny guy a good fun
self-deprecating in grad school like
it's like a guy that I would hang out
with literally
why don't you want to hang out with you
I don't know I I just I've always just
seen sort of the negative and what is my
fault tell me what the negative is
because I I bet this I don't believe you
tell me what the negative is change my
mind
um
well I I
don't know
my mind's gone blank no you've got like
two or three things if you could snap
your fingers and make Drake different
right now what would it be
I wish that I was in better shape okay
uh wish I looked better okay
um what does that mean like
aesthetically
yes okay
um
wish I was more confident
okay
um how do we get confidence
uh well where I've had success in that
area is I I go out and I I accomplish
things and I look back I'm like wow I
can't believe I did that that's the only
way you get confidence is a whole bunch
of little wins piled up
yeah
you can't you can't uh manifest or
whatever they're saying on the internet
these days you can't invent and just
stayed out into the universe I'm
confident it's not like Michael Scott
like I declare bankruptcy that's not how
that works right you can't do that with
confidence yeah you got to go out and do
okay so you wish you were confident you
wish you weighed less what else you wish
you had more muscle tone or whatever
what else
I I don't
those are the two big ones uh what's in
the black hole
because those sit on there I wish I
those sit on top of something else
I've never thought of myself as very
smart so I wish I was I was smarter
um
that's that that's probably one
um who in your life
who in your life has told you
that you are the sum total of all these
extrinsic things
was it your mom
you got to get this many grades
you got to get into this school was it
your dad where did that come from no
coach I I don't
no I think I I think you know my parents
there was a lot of tension in the house
growing up right so
um
you know it was it was really uh
difficult to be at peace so to speak but
I wouldn't say that they ever told me
that that I'm the the the sum total of
that I mean they're always supportive of
me they just hated each other so they
were always yelling but so hey hold on
so just just so you know and if you've
ever listened to show you've probably
heard me talk about this
kids absorb tension in their home
and it's a biological protective measure
but they make that tension their fault
and they try to solve it
that sounds right and many kids will
spend their entire adult lives trying to
solve that childhood tension
and they always if they can't reconcile
it if Mom and Dad never came back around
and solved their marriage issues and
created a warm safe place for a kid to
land
their nervous system knows one Avenue
you're not enough you couldn't get the
job done
and that you're not enough you couldn't
get the job done is that confidence I
know one thing about me I couldn't get
the job done
and that road rat I mean that's the road
you take into jobs into romantic
relationships into friendships into
church groups into bowling leagues into
dance classes that becomes the path
until you decide I'm taking a machete
I'm gonna head off into the woods I'm
going to create a new one because this
path is going to kill me
yeah
and so as I hear you talk I need you to
hear me say this the one the one thing
about this show I promise I'm gonna tell
the truth
you sound like a guy who's a lot of fun
and you sound like a guy who laughs are
you a guy who laughs
oh yeah I can hear it in you number
three you're in grad school what are you
studying
accounting you're not a good God you're
not dumb you train yourself into a human
calculator for God's sakes although
accounting is just like in that kind of
balance sheet like make sure this side's
got more money in this side anyway
yeah you're you're getting a master's in
accountant accountancy is that as they
say
you're not dumb
so here's your path forward okay I'm
gonna give you a couple of things number
one I'm gonna hook you up with my
friends at mind pump and give you access
to any of the workouts that you want on
their whole site for free okay
thank you and you can print it off and
just follow it that's it
at least make a commitment to Drake that
I can do this and you go through there
and pick any ones you want and Jenna
will hook you up with the um those are
some great friends that's the same
workout programs that I use okay so it's
not about mechanics it's about I'm worth
doing that today I'm worth 45 minutes
today I'm worth that okay the second one
is
um
I'm gonna hook you up with my buddy Lane
Norton's uh carbon out okay it's a free
it's a I'm gonna give you a lifetime
free subscription to it and all it is is
just by tracking try tracking calories
okay tracking what I eat
yeah it sucks it sucks tracking stuff
because you can't lie to the to the
calculator but it's also amazing okay
and he's gonna give you that for free
the third thing is
I want you to write a letter
the nine-year-old Drake
and when you write that letter I want
you to sit somewhere quietly by yourself
and I want you to become nine-year-old
Drake again I want you to think of the
house tension the volume in the house or
the silence in the house
that feeling of your dad walking into
the room and your mom's storming another
I want you to feel all of that
and then as 28 year old Drake I want you
to write nine-year-old Drake a letter
and I want you to tell Drake
I'm so sorry
that you tried to carry the stability of
that home
Mom and Dad weren't mad at you
they were dealing with things in their
life that we will that you'll never know
about
but but you're worth being loved and
you're worth having fun and worth having
joy and worth having people like you and
look you in the eye
and then as you said earlier about
confidence
I want 28 year old Drake
to give 28 year old Drake 30 days
and since you mentioned you know working
out we pick that one
but it could have been grad school it
could have been learning a new language
it could have been whatever but will you
give yourself 30 days
and by the way you'll screw up one of
those days I sat with a guy recently um
we're working on a I guess for like a
better terms of TV show and it was a
90-day Challenge and I checked with him
every 30 days and after the first
meeting I told the team there's no
chance he doesn't make 30 days no chance
he made all 90.
and as we said we shot the final episode
last week uh or two weeks ago and he
said 90 days everything's different the
whole thing the whole machine is turned
around
what I'm going to tell you is if you
find somebody that's wonderful and
beautiful and that you're instantly want
to create a connection with and make a
life with
that Drake that you don't like will show
up
and that's not fair to you and that's
not fair to whoever this person is you
want to meet
and so the work is less to be done on
I've got to go Gotta Go Gotta Get gotta
get I hate it that you got it I can't
believe you have you got you're getting
oh even Steve's getting married Steve
sucks he's getting married
right
yeah it's not that it's dude it's so rad
good for you man I don't understand how
you could get married but it's so so
great that there's a glitch in The
Matrix that way that's awesome
that comes from a place of
I'm okay with me
um I had last year own your past change
your future the book sold a bajillion
copies way more than any of us thought I
was gonna sell
and I grew up a real poor kid and
um my wife didn't have a lot grown up
either I don't say I wasn't a poor kid
we didn't have a lot we did very very
little
and I've had the same group of buddies
and all of them have done really really
well and as I was I've I've obviously
done good with my higher ed career and
my team of students jobs and stuff we've
done well but it got silly last year was
a silly year for us
and I called my buddy I said I just need
to tell one person
this is what happened last year
the only person I told an actual number
yeah and he said good God you
and I said I know
and he got quiet
and he said I'm so proud of you I would
start crying if you wouldn't make fun of
me
yeah I had somebody in my corner that
was there for me when things were hard
and he's the guy that I called one time
when I had what I thought was internal
bleeding and I had called him and said
can I borrow your Southwest credit card
so that I can go to the ER and he said I
got you
and he's also the guy that 25 years
later I called and he was like dude I'm
so proud of you
and I want you to start that with Drake
being proud of Drake
look what we're doing man
I'm gonna give myself 30 days I'm gonna
call two buddies and we're just gonna
hang out
and we're going to start building
confidence with a bunch of little wins
the other thing I want you to do is I
want you to start keeping a journal of
the negative self-talk the bull crap
stories you tell yourself
I used to be really overweight and I'm
less of a way to guess I'll call that a
win no
that's a true that's that is a win it's
a huge
some girl wanted to be with me she's
gonna think uh how do you know how do
you know I don't really know cool well
then we're done with that thought
until she says I would love you but you
just are too filming
then we're gonna be sad and grieve that
thought but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
as Renee Brown says I'm not gonna dress
rehearse tragedy I'm not going to
continue to put all these layers in
front of me and laughter and me and joy
and me at home and me in the future
I'm not gonna do that
to wasting my time
it feels protective but it's not
it's isolating
so I just do a lot at you what do you
think
I think I think you're right man and and
you know like I like I started the call
with with you know how blessed I really
am I I do I'm very fortunate I do have
those friends in my life that
are you know there but uh have you have
you said talk to him and been honest
yeah
I don't like I have I don't like Drake
yeah okay I have and
um do they call you out for the bull
crap that is
yeah good no they're they're good
they're good at calling that out yeah
good now everybody needs to take one
step more and say okay we've thought
about this a lot we've talked about this
a lot let's start acting one of the
great curses of modern mental health the
idea of quote-unquote mental health is
if you just get all the right thoughts
in the right order then you're going to
be mentally well and I think that's
false that's a false narrative you have
to go do you have to act you have to you
have to engage
and you have to like you said create
confidence based on I kept showing up
for me
I did an exercise thing for 30 days
without stopping
confidence I can
I tracked what I put in my body for 30
days I can
I took a journal and I wrote down every
time I had a negative thought about me
for 30 days and I challenged those
thoughts some of them are true
do I need to have weight to lose yep
that's still true am I a complete loser
nobody will love me and I'll never have
a romantic relationship because of that
no
not true
and on and on and on but all of this
starts with you looking in the mirror
and saying Drake's worth loving Drake's
worth exercising Drake's worth taking
care of our body Drake is worth
calling his buddies Drake is worth
asking her out even if she's gonna say
no
whatever that may be
thank you for the call my brother hey
I'll walk with you every step of the way
you call if you need something
um if you get 30 days down the road and
you want to call back and I'll celebrate
with you awesome you want to call back
and say I've completely failed I'm gonna
go again I'll cheer you on again
I'm super proud of you brother and I
think this is going to be the day that
everything changes
cheer for your friends man cheer for
your friends
and cheer for Drake